a poco más de un año desde que comenzara
la pandemia de kobe 19 las muertes por
hambre superan a las provocadas por el
virus así lo revela un informe de la
organización humanitaria oxfam las
cifras presentadas apuntan a que al
menos 11 personas mueren cada minuto por
el hambre extrema causada por la
combinación letal de conflictos armados
la crisis climática y el impacto dejado
por la pandemia en general 155 millones
de personas en todo el mundo viven ahora
en niveles de crisis de inseguridad
alimentaria o peor es decir 20 millones
más que el año pasado el informe también
enumera los países denominados como los
peores sitios de hambre entre los cuales
figuran afganistán etiopía sudán del sur
siria y yemen todos ellos envueltos en
conflictos armados el hambre sigue
sirviendo como arma de guerra que priva
a los civiles de alimentos y agua y
obstaculiza la ayuda humanitaria la
gente no puede vivir con seguridad ni
encontrar alimentos cuando sus mercados
son bombardeados y las cosechas y el
ganado
destruidos la organización instó a los
gobiernos a actuar con urgencia para
abordar la inseguridad alimentaria y sus
causas resaltando al mismo tiempo que el
gasto militar mundial aumentó en 51.000
millones de dólares durante la pandemia
una cantidad seis veces superior al
presupuesto que la onu necesita para
acabar con el hambre